From whale mouths to whale memories and Kiri’s
consequential connection – the Tsaheylu is on
full display in “Avatar: The Way of Water”
and it’s complicated beyond connection.
When "Avatar" first came out in 2009, many
were quick to draw comparisons between it
and "Pocahontas" or "Dances With Wolves."
The movie still managed to set itself apart
in terms of its spectacular world-building.
James Cameron and his team created an entire
world and language filled with new animals and
customs, making the movie feel truly lived-in.
The Na'vi felt like a real civilization,
complete with religion based on something real
in the world of Pandora. The Na'vi worship Eywa,
which is based on the real neural connections
that all of the fauna and flora on the planet
remain connected to and in “Avatar: The Way
of Water” they aren’t as simple anymore.
While in the first film, the Na'vi can tap into
this Eywa via the Tsaheylu, which requires them
to connect their ponytails with other materials
to allow them to feel and communicate with what
the other plant or animal is feeling. However,
there's much more to learn about this ability,
and "Avatar: The Way of Water" reveals more
ways the Na'vi can bond with those around them.
“They will be introduced to a new oceanic clan
and an array of diverse aquatic creatures.”
Bonding plays an important part in "Avatar: The
Way of Water," as Jake Sully and Neytiri ride
mountain banshees to get around. Once the two take
their family to the Metkayina clan, they learn how
to bond with ilus and skimwings, which basically
function as their forest-based counterparts,
allowing the Na'vi to travel with ease. However,
the main animal on display in "The Way of Water"
is the tulkun, which is a giant whale-like
creature, but it has a very unique way of bonding.
Instead of attaching to an outer-exposed
mechanism like in the first Avatar,
the Na'vi must enter the tulkun's mouth.
Only there will they find the neural point,
as we see with Lo'ak [LO-ack] and Payakan
– a young tulkun he befriends. However,
Lo'ak doesn't use this
connection to control Payakan.
Instead, he sees what Payakan saw on one
fateful day, which just so happens to be
the reason why the Metkayina and
other tulkuns want nothing to do
with him. They view him as a killer,
which goes against the tulkun way.
Up until this point, we hadn't seen that bonding
could lead to such a phenomenon. Lo'ak actually
watches Payakan's memories, allowing greater
depth and understanding within their bond.
Kiri has her own unique experience with bonding
but with almost tragic consequences. Some kids
from the Metkayina clan take Kiri to a special
place in the reef where she can bond with a
unique structure. When she connects to it, she
receives an image in her head of her speaking
to the human form of Dr. Grace Augustine.
However, things take a dark turn when Kiri
begins seizing underwater, forcing her new
friends to take her to the surface for aid.
It's unclear exactly why bonding caused
Kiri to have a seizure in this instance,
although Dr. Norm Spellman and Dr.
Max Patel insist that it was a form
of epilepsy with the bonding
acting as a kind of trigger.
Sigourney Weaver, who plays Kiri in
the film, did say in an interview
with Screen Rant that Kiri was more deeply
connected to nature than others around her,
so it's possible that had something to
do with the reaction. As she explained:
"There is a scene where she talks about hearing
Eywa's breathing. Eywa is [why] Kiri can hear
things that other people don't hear. I
think it makes Kiri quite uncomfortable,
but I think because she's so sensitive to all of
nature that she would also be sensitive to Eywa."
Clearly, there's more to bonding than
simply being able to ride an animal
around like a pony. With plenty
of sequels reportedly on deck,
chances are good we'll learn more
about bonding in the years to come.